welcome to this video I'm sorry mm of a
sore throat IAM i'm playing a 15 minute
game I got requests to play some longer
time control games rapid games I'm going
to play a few and post one daily in the
next couple of days the channel will
have about an hour of content anyway
soon per day it's just a bit of yeah
matter of time when I will start to
expand this to about one hour and for
the moment i'll do some some rapid games
but i'll have some other content as well
ok we have the semi Slav now I'm going
to play you three year the shop g5 I
don't really know that well try to to
play him in a more positional manner
what Bishop g5 is of course also not
anti positional or anything but can lead
to a very tricky play I don't know
anything about the bot Vinick variation
for example oh ha ok I'm his planks is
65 here in this some in the structure
you know this can easily be the loss of
a tempo hmm not clear how I should
respond there are many possible moves I
move the bishop it can happen that black
takes on c4 Bishop c4 and I'm losing in
tempo and then some sort maybe maybe
let's play clay loams like that and ask
like what is going to do if is taking
are basically gain a temple and one idea
could be to take on c5 if he recaptures
with the piece of
before and there should be two so a
3some multifunctional move what should
like to know that he is flexible c65 is
some sometimes somewhat strange but it's
not necessarily am so terrible if the
now continues to develop and not lose
any more time yeah this is this is a
possibility of course wait if I take on
let's let's check briefly if I take on
d5 pawn takes can I take with the knight
Knight takes Knight takes d5 Queenie for
check hmmmm swinging a pawn you can take
with the the night of course but this is
not really desirable let's do that pawn
takes Knight XD 590 xt5 Queenie for
check there should be 725 2725 always
winning upon at night is 7 i'm going to
take the rook and he's got no way I
think to to trap the Queen okay so
probably he needs to take with the night
and as mentioned this is not a very
desirable move yes because of many
things first I'll take this to save some
time this is what i need to do anyway
and now one point is that is got some
weaknesses on the light squares a move
like Bishop b5 might be might be
problematic already a 6 Bishop see six
wins the d5 pawn bishop be 795 young is
a very nasty pin on Bishop b5 he
probably needs to play chef it probably
needs to play a move like Quincy 7
and after that I have many ideas some
very director dis like Queen f5 for
example okay i'm going to do that pose
him some problems I don't think that
like an black an cannot play em and
nothing moves now as Bishop c6 is severe
threat there should be 795 as mentioned
as almost deadly the abbey probably is
deadly Bishop see ages I don't think I
move that black and can afford to do
Queen a 5s also not so possible but
Quincy seven is quite clearly them the
move that black probably should do now
and after Queen at five the question is
how does he defend the d5 ball maybe
with a 6mm I know didn't know I can't
play Bishop c6 and win the d phi upon he
needed to play quincy seven after that
it's not entirely clear maybe we can we
can check this afterwards ok but let's
first make sure that i finish this off
correctly there I should take I think I
don't have any thing to gain by 95 or
something like that this is a very very
important central pawn yeah I can take
even another pawn yeah no reason not to
really let's just take it there's also
95 now yeah 95 is a big problem how to
see protect f7 now Bishop e6 is not
really playable I mean what else should
he do but there should be six
can be answered by by many Betty good
moves take Quinn c6 check yeah now he
needs to play King e71 which is really a
disaster 1936 even this is also ok he
allows the capture Jim well i don't
think i have no reason not to just grab
this and queen bee three intending queen
before with almost made ya shouldn't be
too bad yeah this is some one problem of
the 15 minutes pool you once in a while
get really very very big mismatches in
rating while it rarely happens in the
blitz games and the rapid games here you
see 600 points difference which is quite
substantial very hard for him this this
match ok let's see yeah Queen check
that's Queen d6 walking a king back ok
so probably just the smooth intending
Bishop before check and maybe at the
right moment look see one
Roxy one he might answer with the Queen
Queen capture on c1 so I shouldn't do
that instantly probably we are now but
should not be sure before Nets the Queen
this is too good to pass up let's just
win the queen of it this is a funny
funny self pin let's let's see if i take
here you can take on e5 yeah i would
like to really winner how we look not
just not just an exchange yeah of course
I can take green tags and play a c6
check King t8 engine just take this
seven now okay I mean it's just you can
only on one point purchase game so this
is some really enough I could also take
on b6 just trying to promote the pawn
and Jim you know k let's win the PCM
this is completely sufficient
so what enjoys an extra look for no
particular compensation
yeah I'm the interesting point here was
after 10 Bishop b5 how black should
defend this is something that I can look
at after the game I wasn't so sure how
to how to continue at this point if he
goes Queen c7 it's not not so clear yeah
now is letting the clock run down come
on okay in the meantime we can we can
check this out briefly a Quincy seven I
can of course well during the the game
is still on so I cannot draw any arrows
and stuff or put any variations on the
board Quincy seven was what i was
thinking about protecting the c6 squares
of bishop see success when I we made a
move Queen g5 yeah probably just just
castles
Luke c1 rook c8 is one one possible way
to to get the look into the game
yawa Queenie six Queenie eight not not
bad yeah probably probably this is good
enough keeping this this pawn maybe Lucy
one was even cook I don't know but
Queenie a this is quite okay
yeah I can can we capture I'll give the
check first yeah I guess I just take
also opening up the eighth the a look
here and so yeah now the concrete made
threats Queen yet check King see said I
can go to the section yeah well okay
Queenie I check King c7 look see one
yeah I can play that now or not let's
briefly check this y mal were looking at
even simpler mate I don't know y'all can
serve this is okay so Luke see one look
a seven yeah look is set on the same
probably even better I in fact that the
maiden to me so here's the the mage
delivered gaining one rating point from
the game yeah the the critical position
really was here after this should be
five where I think he probably basically
only has Quincy's have another computer
gives Queen f6 yeah I didn't see that
move to cover to cover c6 this is maybe
better to be honest because after that I
thought Queen a five would be very good
and it probably is here black has some
has no decent move I'm attacking d5 how
do you protect it very very difficult
Bishop d7 95 is this winning winning
straight away and you cannot move the
night that is obviously pinned if
there's a six I have Queen Anne I g5
yeah this is a disaster so Quincy 7 is
losing straight away even which I mean I
saw that Karina 5 is strong but I wasn't
100% sure if he's got some sort of
defense like Akamai I like giving up the
porn for example but the problem is if
you look at this there's also this move
it's very direct but how does he protect
it there's no way to do it castles
bluntness queen age 7 mate so it's
already very critical here which means
that this is really the only move and
that's really bad news if you need to
ply Queen f6 it does not look very
healthy yeah just castle is good the
idea being to play e4 open up the e-file
black is terribly terribly badly
coordinated let's say a move like that
to develop yeah this even Queen a for a
very very crude stuff but about this is
strong simply five threatened young
black is in bad shape I think that
probably LOL c5 is questionable while I
don't know a three is the play will move
from nothing special but here this
already is a bit tricky the problem is
that what you would like to do because
you want p.m. to to be better prepared
for move like we should be five you want
to take with the porn but as I mentioned
this is a move that winsor the porn and
probably probably the game in the long
run I'm just winning material this even
the exchange with no compensation and
this Nets the d5 pawn and yeah maybe
maybe black should try that yeah it's
it's still just a pawn probably for know
from
were completely sufficient compensation
yeah so this leads to leads to trouble
already mean meaning that b6 is
questionable what black should do
probably is to develop something like
Bishop e7 or you can yeah Bishop e7 is
probably probably am a decent move and
it's there's nothing special happening I
mean c65 is some bit fishy but shouldn't
use the game of course okay thanks for
watching